plus qu'un petit nouveau intégré la
bande c'est fabien lecoeuvre il connaît
tout surtout voulu dit un truc qui vous
donne une date voulue tout une date si
vous donnez un nom voulu donner un amas
de leurs maux de leurs mots par exemple
ce que vous avez un truc sur lui de
leurs maux oui j'étais présent quand il
a changé de partenaire pendant un
concert de madonna parce que toi tu
balances des beaux jamais d'oiseaux
quand vous offrez un cadeau à jenifer
c'est à dire elle est là il faut because
oiseaux mais que tu crois c'est vraiment
qu'un mec qui justement les pigeons il y
en a qui étaient rentrés dans votre
chambre respect de leurs sous la couette
à la pause et sortir ressortir de la cua
mais on s'en fout
une info sur marrakech merci non la
sienne propre
j'y vais assez prochainement
[Rires]
alors braguette ouverte c'est arrivé à
fabien lecoeuvre un jour il ya eu
d'évacuation des locaux les genres
dionne a retrouvé le monstre du loch
ness
on va donner la parole à quelqu'un qui
va calmer les esprits qui va dire
quelque chose dont on se fout
certainement fabien moi j'ai vendu il ya
14000 euros
ah ouais enfin chez experts pour les
tribunaux vous savez c'était le string
et la culotte de joséphine baker
allez on va faire un soudeur sujet avec
fabien lecoeuvre
je suis bon ouais mais je m'en bats les
couilles mes gars comme toi mais
malheureusement il n'a pas vécu ce qu'on
parle de slimane et il appelait à faire
une surprise
[Musique]
on fait une très belle entrée audio on
dirait le papa de kernilis a rigolé ne
s'est pas passé c'est ton papa vous avez
une info sur les marseillais vous non
mais ça tout le monde par le marseillais
qui enverrait tout le monde chez
l'orthophoniste mois pour parler non ce
faut savoir que le métier de chanteur
qui nous a donné là bas je sais pas je
suivais vote doit arriver non je suis à
toi tu dois arriver
le petit est ce que vous avez des
rituels avant une émission nombre que
moi j'ai rien moi aussi tu t'habilles
mal qui dormait en taule à la couarde
dors bien quoi tu dors bien toi tu as tu
des cinq heures ses doigts talibés
fabien le cas vous êtes numéro trois
c'est votre meilleur classement j'ai vu
les douze coups de minuit de ne pas de
mini coup de midi de plus il est donc
cette femme elle avait données
démontrent à ses chats 22 boussoufa
[Applaudissements]
hier c'était 97000 aujourd'hui c'est 120
125 500 à 8 500 tu viens d'avoir les
chiffres de recherche l'universal à 18h
d'accord a battu vallée rappelé 19h50
est ce que tu peux nous faire une petite
imitation demande s'il te plaît femme
est le coeur de sortir va bien est ce
que tu peux sortir lui qui aurait
conduit nos sous qu'on vienne au secours
de shine c'est bien sûr c'est normal moi
je tenais son frère harry il est
martiniquais
on s'en fout